did you see what happened with Target
Target I think yesterday announced that
because of organized retail crime they
lost 400 million dollars this year for
think about that 400 hold that up 400
million dollars because they're saying
organized crime but like Pat and Cali
they lowered that thing where you could
steal under a thousand bucks and just
the cops won't even come after you you
know yeah San Francisco 500.
organized retail crime
400 million Vinnie are you thinking
about it I'm thinking like a side uh I
mean think about it in California you
could if you think about it uh Pat Tom
you could go into every Walmart every
CVS steal under a thousand dollars
they're not even chasing you people are
just recording it and they put it on you
know world star and YouTube and you
could just get dude if you hit four of
those a day go to another city that's
you and just sell it on on Amazon you
want to go into business with me or like
what are we talking about right I mean
as much as we're having fun with this
story this is not funny it's not funny
if your target yeah and
this is just Target blames organized
retail crime for 400 million dollars
loss in profits this year that's insane
to be thinking about right that this is
now a business model for some that's
what yeah I would love to know that
breakdowns for a state like what state
California
I'm saying Target loses 1 million one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a day
on theft yeah well I've traced on this
number that's insane can you zoom in a
little bit I'm trying to find September
okay let me just read that one right
there in September the CEO of Rite Aid
said Tyler can you zoom in please a
little bit yeah there you go uh so the
pharmacy chain was burdened with a five
million year over year increasing in a
shrink a term in a retail industry which
means losses related to theft fraud or
administrative errors right at CEO uh
done again told analysts that the
problem was particularly cute in New
York City there you go I think the
headline here is the environment that we
operate in particularly in New York City
is not conducted of conducive to
reducing shrink just based upon
everything you read and see on social
media and the news and the city who's uh
who's the big uh singer is it Selena
Selena Gomez her brother got robbed and
shot or something in New York City did
you see that it was recent somebody did
somebody did just get shot I don't know
if it was Selena who's the other girl
it's um
who's who's uh uh Ariana Grande I'm
sorry Ariana Grande's brother type in
Ariana's there you go and then go to
news
Ariana Grande's brother Frankie Grande
39 viciously mugged in New York City by
13 years 13 year old kid can you imagine
that what go down to see if he was shot
or was just a mug zoom in a little bit
Ariana Grande's brother Frankie Grande
was viciously mugged by 13 year old punk
and another scene in Midtown Manhattan
Frankie's social media personality and a
39 Year brother popular pop star working
on some religion Avenue between 43rd and
44th Street around 6 PM it's not even
Dark Yet on November night when it was
attacked in front of Saturn dolls
gentlemen's club and sports bar cops his
mugger is a 13 year old boy and a 17
year old film smashed Frankie in the
back of the head cop said and uh he's
hanging out he's hanging out one of
those late night uh gentlemen clubs
those libraries
networking events what are your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]